[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con tras una
convulsa situación política a armenia
celebró elecciones parlamentarias
anticipadas el 20 de junio pese a las
críticas que ha vivido el primer
ministro niccoló pasini antes de la rede
derrota de su país frente a azerbaiyán
en el conflicto de nagorno karabaj el
año pasado su partido obtuvo la mayoría
en el parlamento analizamos este tema de
la mano de diego cara manukian analista
internacional y director del programa
radial armenio radio ara c's gracias por
su tiempo y bienvenido a france 24 todos
los sondeos daban como perdedor al
partido pacto cívico de para xinjiang
como se interpretan entonces estos
resultados con la victoria de su partido
lo que se tiene que afirmar es que para
definir las autoridades hay que realizar
elecciones y no encuestas las encuestas
tienen un alto grado de error al menos
lo demostró esto en armenia lo que queda
claro es que la gente la mayoría del
pueblo de armenia apoya pajín ya no
apoya a su partido lo ha votado y
armenia transitará por el camino de la
solución de los problemas y es una señal
interesante desde lo interno hacia lo
externo ya que pajín ya no es la persona
que si bien perdió la guerra comenzó el
proceso de reformas en relación a el
respeto del estado de derecho y a pesar
de la guerra página es el que firmó el
acuerdo la declaración que le puso fin a
la guerra por lo tanto el mundo ya tiene
experiencia de relación con nicole para
xinjiang estas elecciones fueron
convocadas para poner fin precisamente a
la crisis del gobierno desatada por este
conflicto de nagorno karabaj supone en
estos resultados el fin de dicha crisis
no se puede afirmar eso teniendo en
cuenta que la parte perdedora que estuvo
en el poder ha dicho que pajín ya no es
un enemigo o sea no un rival político y
se especula que ingresando al parlamento
puedan realizar algún tipo de acciones
incluso lo han dicho públicamente el ex
presidente robert kocharián oriundo del
alto karabaj que fue elegido siempre en
forma dudosa y cuestionada y también
produjo
acciones de violencia desde desde el
gobierno ha dicho que en el parlamento
si bien no confirmó que él personalmente
va a ingresar al parlamento en el
parlamento harán todo lo posible para
llegar al poder siendo oposición lo que
hace una base de que tendremos el
tensión a pesar de que el pueblo apoya
página en su mayoría la atención
persistirá y también eso se puede
afirmar ya que armenia tiene desafíos
importantes como por ejemplo el
cumplimiento de ese acuerdo o de esa
declaración con azerbaiyán
y también que hoy siguen estando
soldados azerbaiyanos ocupando el
territorio legítimo de armenia lo que si
bien las elecciones terminaron hay
muchos problemas por resolver la
oposición ya ha anunciado que va a
impugnar los resultados señalando que
hubo supuesto fraude hay pruebas de
estas presuntas irregularidades
los observadores internacionales
he reconocido que las elecciones han
sido excelentes han sido muy buenas
obviamente que es siempre hay
irregularidades lo que pasa es que los
opositores y amigos sorprendidos por esa
gran diferencia entre todos los sondeos
y el resultado real las elecciones no
creo que exista posibilidad para
modificar incluso eso ya han dado
declaraciones en los expresidentes y han
dado señales de que no tienen más
remedio que reconocer incluso el ex
presidente serzh sarkisián ha reconocido
que pajín ya ha ganado en armenia
siempre sucede eso o sea siempre en la
parte perdedora
no accede a saludar al ganador y
cuestiona pero con el paso de los días
todo eso se va diluyendo y comienza de
alguna forma a formarse los dos bloques
en el gobierno que tiene un 54% y la
oposición con un 21 pues muchísimas
gracias digo karamanus jan por ayudarnos
a comprender un poquito más acerca de la
situación que vive armenia en esos
momentos a ustedes
sigan con más en france 24 punto com
[Música]